>>> IN OUR SPORTS LEAD, THE
BIGGEST SCANDAL IN THE HTORY
OF ALETICS.
TODAY, MORE THAN 90 WOMEN AND
GIRLS SEXUALLY ABUSED BY
CONVICTED CHILD MOLESTER AND
FORMER TEAM USA GYMNASTICS
DOCTOR LARRY NASSAR ARE SEEKING
MORE THAN A BILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE FBI.
THE GYMNASTS SAY INVESTIGATORS
COULD HAVE ENDED NASSAR'S ABUSE
AND PROTECTED THEM AND OTHER
VICTIMS HAD FBI AGENTS NOT
MISHANDLED THE CASE, CLAIMANTS
INCLUDE SIMONE BILEScKAYLA MARO.
AND AS JEAN CASAREZ REPORTS FOR
US, AUTHORITIES NOW HAVE SIX
MONTHS TO SETTLE THE CLAIMS
BEFORE A LAWSUIT CAN BE FILED IN
FEDERAL COURT.
>> THE FBI ON OFFICIAL NOTICE.
>> WE HAVE BEEN FAILED AND WE
DESERVE ANSWERS.
>> 90 FEMALE ATHLETES VICTIMIZED
BY DISGRACED DOCTOR LARRY NASSAR
SEEKING MORE THAN A BILLION
DOLLARS IN DAMAGES FROM THE
AGENCY IN ADMINISTRATIVE CLAIMS,
A REQUIRED STEP BEFORE A LAWSUIT
CAN BE FILED.
>> I BLAME LARRY NASSAR.
AND I ALSO BLAME AN ENTIRE
SYSTEM THAT ENABLED AND
PERPETRATED HIS ABUSE.
>> THE FBI'S INDIANAPOLIS FIELD
OFFICE WAS NOTIFIED IN 2015 THAT
NASSAR, A LONGTIME TEAM DOCTOR
FOR U.S. OLYMPIC GYMNASTICS AND
MICHIGAN STATE UNIVERSITY, HAD
SEXUALLY ABUSED FEMALE GYMNASTS.
>> I THEN PROCEEDED TO TELL THEM
ABOUT LONDON AND HOW HE WOULD
SIGN ME UP LAST ON HIS SHEET SO
HE COULD MOLEST ME FOR HOURS A
DAY.
I TOLD THEM HOW HE MOLESTED ME
RIGHT BEFORE I WON MY TEAM GOLD
MEDAL.
>> THE FBI INTERVIEWED THE
ATHLETES, BUT ACCORDING TO AN
INSPECTORS GENERAL REPORT,
SENIOR OFFICIALS, QUOTE, FAILED
TO RESPOND WITH THE UTMOST
SERIOUSNESS AND URGENCY.
MADE NUMEROUS ERRORS, AND FAILED
TO, QUOTE, TAKE STEPS TO
MITIGATE THE ONGOING THREAT
POSED BY NASSAR.
>> I AM HAUNTED BY THE FACT THAT
EVEN AFTER REPORTING MY ABUSE,
SO MANY WOMEN AND GIRLS HAD TO
SUFFER AT THE HANDS OF LARRY
NASSAR.
>> THE INSPECTOR GENERAL ALSO
FOUND THE FBI SUPERVISORY
SPECIAL AGENT MADE FALSE
STATEMENTS TO INVESTIGATORS, IN
AN EFFORT TO MINIMIZE OR EXCUSE
HIS ERRORS.
>> WHAT IS THE POINT OF
REPORTING ABUSE IF OUR OWN FBI
AGENTS ARE GOING TO TAKE IT UPON
THEMSELVES TO BURY THAT REPORT
IN A DRAWER?
>> NASSAR WAS CONVICTED IN 2017
AND SENTENCED UP TO 175 YEARS IN
STATE PRISON.
>> IMAGINE FEELING LIKE YOU HAVE
NO POWER AND NO VOICE.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT, LARRY?
I HAVE BOTH POWER AND VOICE AND
I'M ONLY BEGINNING TO JUST USE
THEM.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DECLINED MULTIPLE TIMES TO
PROSECUTE THE FBI EMPLOYEES
INVOLVED.
IT WOULD NOT COMMENT ON THESE
NEW CLAIMS, BUT THE FBI HAS
PREVIOUSLY CONDEMNED THE
CONDUCT.
>> THE ACTIONS AND INACTION OF
THE FBI EMPLOYEES DETAILED IN
THIS REPORT ARE TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> THE FBI CAN NOW RESPOND TO
THE ATHLETES' CLAIMS.
IF THEY ARE NOT SETTLED IN SIX
MONTHS, THE ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING THEM CAN FILE A
LAWSUIT.
>> IT DISGUSTS ME THAT WE ARE
STILL FIGHTING FOR THE MOST
BASIC ANSWERS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OVER SIX YEARS LATER.
>> ATTORNEY JOHN MANLY OUT OF
CALIFORNIA HAS STOOD BY THE SIDE
OF ALL OF THESE VICTIMS FROM THE
BEGINNING, PURSUING FOR THEM
JUSTICE.
THEY HAVE BEEN AT THIS FOR A
LONG TIME, MANY OF THESE WOMEN
WERE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED WHEN
THEY WERE IN THEIR TEENS.
NOW, WE ARE 2022, AND THEY ARE
FINALLY ASKING THE FBI ONE LAST
TIME POSSIBLY, WE DESERVE
JUSTICE.
JAKE.
>> JEAN CASAREZ, THANKS.
HERE TO DISCUSS, SPORTS ANALYST
AND USA TODAY COLUMNIST
CHRISTINE BRENNAN.
OLYMPIC GOLD MEDALIST McKAYLA
MARONEY RELEASED A STATEMENT
ABOUT WHY THEY'RE FILING THIS
CLAIM.
IT READS, MY FELLOW SURVIVORS
AND I WERE BETRAYED BY EVERY
INSTITUTION THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT US.
I HAD SOME HOPE AFTER WE POURED
OUT OUR HEARTS TO THE U.S.
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
BEGGED FOR JUSTICE.
IT'S CLEAR THE ONLY PATH TO
JUSTICE AND HEALING IS THROUGH
THE LEGAL PROS.
WE ALL REMEMBER THAT INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL HEARING LAST YEAR.
IT IS STUNNING THAT THE FBI DID
NOT CHOOSE TO PROSECUTE.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THIS?
>> IT'S SO REPREHENSIBLE, JAKE.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS AND
EVERY TIME YOU HEAR ABOUT THIS,
EVERY TIME WE TALK ABOUT IT,
JEAN'S REPORT, YOU JUST GET
ANGRY ALL OVER AGAIN.
WHAT THIS NATION FAILED TO DO
FOR THESE WOMEN, FORGET FOR A
MOMEN THEY'RE HEROES AND YOU'RE
CHEERING FOR THEM, IT'S THE RED,
WHITE, AND BLUE, AND THEY'RE
WINNING MEDALS AND THEY'RE GREAT
ROLE MODELS.
FORGET ALL THAT, AMERICAN WOMEN,
GIRLS AND WOMEN, TO BE FAILED SO
MISERABLY BY EVERYTHING.
U.S. OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC
COMMITTEE, USA GYMNASTICS,
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THE FBI.
IT WAS TWO WEEKS AGO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT DECIDED NOT TO
PROSECUTE THE TWO AGENTS WHO SO
EGREGIOUSLY TABLED THIS
HORRIFYING NEWS THAT THEY HEARD
IN 2015.
ALLOWING PERHAPS ANOTHER 100
WOMEN TO BE ABUSED BY LARRY
NASSAR BEFORE ANYONE WOKE UP TO
WHAT THEY WERE HEARING IN
INDIANAPOLIS BEFORE MAKING A
PHONE CALL TO MICHIGAN.
THE MOST BASIC FBI WORK FAILED
TO DO IT, AND THEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FAILS TO PROSECUTE
THEM.
THIS IS WHY WE'RE SEEING THIS
LAWSUIT TODAY.
>> TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT
THREE-TIME OLYMPIC GOLD MEDALIST
ALY RAISMAN TOLD ME LAST YEAR.
>> I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE FBI, USAGA,
AND ALSO LOOKING AT THE
INTERPLAY AMONG ALL THREE
ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T HAVE ANSWERS, THEN WE'RE
RELYING ON GUESSWORK, AND PEOPLE
THAT ENABLED OUR ABUSE MIGHT
STILL BE IN POSITIONS OF POWER.
SO SAYING THAT YOU'RE SORRY OR
WE WILL NEVER FORGET THIS WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN, IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THOSE ARE JUST EMPTY PROMISES.
>> IT'S REALLY INTERESTING THAT
SHE CITED IN THAT INTERVIEW
THREE ORGANIZATIONS THAT SHE
WANTED THERE TO BE AN
INVESTIGATION OF.
ONE WAS USA OLYMPIC COMMITTEE,
ONE WAS USA GYMNASTICS AND THE
THIRD WAS THE FBI.
>> RIGHT.
THE FAILURE THERE IS, AGAIN,
EXTRAORDINARY.
IT'S BRITHTAKING, YOU KIND OF
CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT THESE YOUNG
WOMEN, THEY DID THE RIGHT THING.
THEY CALLED THE FBI.
THEY CALLED THE AUTHORITIES.
THEY SAID, HELP, AND THE FBI
FAILED TO HELP THEM.
U.S. OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC
COMMITTEE DID HAVE A MAJOR
INVESTIGATION.
ALL NEW LEADERSHIP OF THE USOPCA
LOT OF THE BAD PEOPLE ARE GONE.
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
THIS.
USA GYMNASTICS HAD ABOUT FOUR
DIFFERENT LEADERS, STILL CONCERN
ABOUT THAT, BUT THERE HAS BEEN A
CHANGE.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S OVER, BUT
THERE ARE NEW PEOPLE.
THE FBI, THOUGH, AGAIN, ONE WAS
LET GO OF THE TWO AGENTS WHO
BLEW IT BACK IN 2015.
ONE WAS LET GO, THE OTHER
RETIRED.
AND THESE WOMEN CONTINUE TO HAVE
TO FIGHT, AND WHEN THEY DO THIS,
JAKE, AS YOU KNOW, THEY TALK
ABOUT HOW THIS PLUNGES THEM ONCE
AGAIN INTO THE HORRORS OF LARRY
NASSAR.
SO WE AS A NATION ARE MAKING
THEM RELIVE THIS SO THAT THEY
CAN FIGHT THESE BATTLES AND
HOPEFULLY GET JUSTICE IN THE
END.
>> YEAH, THEY'RE FIGHTING THESE
BATTLES FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS
OF BOYS AND GIRLS, AND IT'S A
SHAME THAT WE RELY UPON THEM TO
DO AND CAN'T RELY ON OUR LEADERS
TO DO IT, BUT GOD BLESS THEM.
THEY'RE AMERICAN HEROES.
>> THEY ARE.
THEY ABSOLUTELY ARE.
I COVERED A LOT OF THEM OVER THE
YEARS, AND THEIR WR WONDERFUL
PEOPLE.
OF COURSE, SIMONE BILES WITH THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH.
SO THEY CONTINUE TO LEAD AND BE
THE CONSCIENCE